nicolas rey bon soir séverine ferrer
mariée mère de famille a très bien
nicolas rey célibataire prêt à tout ça
va nicolas très bien ah qu'il est beau
nom
allait mal et oui oui il est vachement
bien nicolas mais magnifique
vous n'avez pas l'air convaincu
craque pas au premier abord comme ça
faut 20 minutes
et un très bon oui un très bon regard
mais en même temps vous êtes mariés vous
avez des enfants et c'est surtout à
croire au père noël
me collard et donc après 13 minutes
mémoire courte et un début prometteur
vous publié au diable vauvert courir à
30 ans vous êtes un petit peu le
prototype de ce qu'on peut appeler le
nouvel homme nom d'une certaine façon
pourquoi je sais pas vous avez cette
fragilité
du nouvel homme le nouvel homme pleure
au cinéma non par exemple ah oui ça
m'est arrivé de plus reçu neininger
fleuret pour un lundi matin au pathé
wepler pour sur la route de madison
parce que c'était lundi matin
non non c'était parce que j'avais pas
encore vu le film devait être baffie que
j'ai toujours pas vu d'ailleurs mais je
vais le voir bien c'est bon tout le
monde te parle de tenter j'en envie de
le voir maintenant il est plus au cinéma
c'est quand elle était dans les salles
ça les dérangeait pas devenir un film
culte non mais vous avez par exemple
centristes j'ai plus rien rien bambi tu
as quand même c'est quand le chasseur
étude la maman tâche allait sa nouvelle
offre voilà mesdames c'est un mec qui
dit je t'aime uniquement par texto c'est
vrai nicolas bal et ouais enfin par
texto ouais c'est vrai que les textos ça
a changé pas mal de choses sinon même
mois passé des choses vous envoyer des
textos cela
s'est passé les sentiments par les
textos mais plutôt à votre mari à vos
amants comment ça se passe
c'est un nouvel homme sa nouvelle
nouvelle année les prêts à tout donner
pour un baiser mais rien pour une vie de
couple par exemple c'est vrai dans
l'instant oui c'est vrai est ce que le
nouvel homme pratique le cunnilingus
avant qu'on lui propose une fellation
ça y est pas grave
l'intérêt
même sens fellation un tu vas
heureusement c'est quand même un endroit
quand on fait l'amour avec quelqu'un
quand on baise avec quelqu'un c'est
quand même l'un des derniers endroits où
il n'y a pas de compétition on a un peu
la paix dont quand on a le droit
d'embrasser une fille entre les cuisses
sans forcément attendre comme dans le
libre échange une fellation en retour
quoi je pense donc c'est ça un nouvel
homme tu vois séverine si si vous avez
pas fait que vous voulez un fait ça
donne envie forcément évidemment
finalement les jets ont bien reçu le
message chez eux je prédis que ça il va
et veut même séverine vous aimez donc
bien conjuguer sais bien que je gagne
c'est bien quand je gage m'en donnez
donc courir à 30 ans raconte la vie de
cinq homme de 30 ans confronté chacun au
choix de la séparation ou de
l'engagement dans le couple bref être ou
ne pas être ce que vous appelez victime
volontaire du couple ça veut dire quoi
ça victime volontaire du couple c'est
parce que quand même aujourd'hui tout le
monde a peur donc on a peur quand on est
célibataire et puis on a peur aussi
quand on est célibataire on a peur de ne
pas trouver quelqu'un ne pas s'engager
ne pas être en couple et quand on est en
couple on a peur de ne jamais être à
nouveau célibataire donc et on a peur de
tout on a peur d'avoir un enfant on a
peur de ne jamais en avoir on a
constamment peur donc une victime
volontaire de la vie en couple c'est
quelqu'un qui à reculons décide à un
moment donné de se mettre en couple à
défaut d'avoir
réalisé un peu le
l'idéal
amoureux qui l'avait quand il avait 14
ans et puis regardez vite veretout un
abîme 2 cambre ta van bree toi oui j'ai
compris et je suis assez d'accord avec
lui on peut choisir est sauf la faim et
la mère des jeunes et prochain mais
c'est là c'est vrai que tout le monde a
peur les gens ont peur de s'engager ils
ont peur de take quelqu'un l'a peut-être
quelqu'un tu as peur d'avoir de ne pas
voir de ne pas pouvoir avoir des enfants
tu as peur d'en avoir cessé la victime
volontaire du koala ben oui c'est ça au
montage tu t'en fous oui je crois il
intéresse a commencé parce que j'ai pas
compris
alors courir à 30 on rencontre la vie de
cinq homme de 30 ans confronté chacun au
choix de la la séparation ou
l'investissement dans le couple bref
être ou ne pas être ce que vous appelez
une victime volontaire du couple c'est
quoi une victime volontaire du couple
ces calculs c'est quelque chose de tout
à fait particulier
c'est quoi
je vais essayer je crois que c'est clair
dire
quelque chose à boire des béliers
c'est à dire en fait je vais essayer
d'expliquer les choses un peu ça plus
simplement en fait par exemple prenons
l'exemple de séverine
séverine avec frédéric son sang il
s'appelle frédéric s'appelle frédéric
avant d'inscrire
c'est compliqué d'expliquer la lenteur
du petit younes et séverine par exemple
et comme nous tous une victime
volontaire de la vie en couple c'est à
dire que avant d'inscrire dans le temps
une histoire
dans sa vie amoureuse séverine a eu
d'autres histoires avant non je pense
avec des jeux c'est pas gentil
est en fait avant de t'engager avec
frédéric tu as voilà est inconnu avant
d'engager de tangage avec frédéric tu as
eu un peu peur quoi en fait il a fallu
que je passe par là pour me rendre
compte enfin de me rendre compte que
c'était vraiment le bout donc non je
suis le couple c'est magique ben on lui
dit que tu es une victime de lenteurs du
couple non mais c'est vrai qu'à un
moment on a toujours peur s'est jamais
le moment n'est jamais prêt pour un
enfant on n'est pas sur steam et je
t'aime moi non plus et un moment si on
n'ose pas les choses on y viendra jamais
donc
je suis très heureuse et puis je suis en
couple c'est bon c'est une vidéo
volontaire du tout me connaître
saleh la patate nico
volontaire de l'avion en couple c'est
quelqu'un qui
a peur et qui va malgré tout et en même
temps donc il se considère comme une
victime plomb terre donc cette personne
à perdre
bon alors c'est simple une victime
volontaire de la vie en couple c'est pas
compliqué une victime volontaires de la
ville est ce que ton éditeur
il est là ou pas parce que je dois être
les sens en grande forme
une victime volontaire de la vie en
couple gt c'est quelqu'un qui accepte de
nos jours et ce n'est pas évident
l'amour sans les détritus ce voilà ça
c'est sa voix là bas ce sera coupée au
montage
qui arrivait enfin là c'est simple avant
en gros nos grands parents pour donner
des exemples un peu concrets pour éviter
que certaines personnes ne comprennent
pas avant nos grands parents quand ils
avaient du pain par exemple le lendemain
le pain dur il en fait il le
transformait en levure il le donnée aux
poules ils ont fait du pain perdu
lendemain matin et de nos jours on zappe
tout c'est pas évident ou d'inscrire une
histoire non pas dans la durée parce que
si on n'a pas droit de citer de marque
mais dans le couple et à partir de là et
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on
à partir de là on est tous là en fait à
zapper en permanence là c'était bien sûr
séverine et pas assez grande 11 ap de
séverine non il faut garder séverine
avec sa taille de lolita c'est essentiel
il faut inscrire une histoire dans le
temps c'est à dire que aussi vous
voudrez si vous voulez en parler
il faut aimer séverine et compris avec
ses défauts bien avec ses fantômes sont
compris avec ses névroses oui alors
c'est ça une victime volontaire de la
vie en couple c'est elle que ses défauts
mais voilà pourquoi tu veux pas du tout
si tu veux vraiment
voilà trente ans raconte la venue de 52
30 en mai et qui anglais non monsieur le
piège du moins je rémy de ra à courir
non ah ouais tu mettrais 2h toi oui
alors on va prendre quelques hommes
parmi parmi les cinq que vous décrivez
nicolas rey ya franck alors vous avez
une phrase qui est très jolie d'ailleurs
en parlant de francs vous dites les vies
sont ainsi faites elles tiennent le coup
des décennies entières puis bascule sur
un baiser et c'est vrai qu'il est
heureux il est en coupe justement dépit
rencontre une femme ici que ça va être
voilà c'est ça va être une catastrophe
jeudi va quand même assez comme ça on a
la sensation parfois d'accéder à une
certaine sérénité une certaine
tranquillité d'avoir enfin trouvé
un équilibre et puis d'avoir enfin
quelques certitudes et puis c'est pas du
tout prévu tu te réveille un matin et
puis tu crois que quelqu'un est sur un
baiser toute ta vie va basculer tu dois
faire encore et parfois comme ça le
temps ce serait très si sur quelques sur
quelques secondes quoi il faut pas faire
tel corps demain mais c'est vachement
bien son truc pourquoi doller
et et donc des enquêtes craque pour
cette gonzesse ouais mais ça c'est en
fait il ya un film de hal hartley
cap a très bien marché mais qui était
très bien qui s'appelle
les gens osent pas mais
ils n'osent pas parler de films qui
marchent vers commençait bien filmé qui
a eu un grand succès d estime de ses
îles et qui va devenir culte bien débuté
oui en dvd qu'un film de hal hartley
mais il ya d'autres films qui vont avoir
ce même destin et
s'appelle le titre c'est très strict et
en fait l'histoire de francs que ça
vient de là c'est qu'à un moment dans le
trust me le héros du film tombe amoureux
comme ça alors qu'il est marié que sa
vie un peu rangé comme ça dans dans une
armoire comme dans un com le bonheur
parfois rangés dans une armoire et puis
bah comme août un enfant elle était
rangée dans une valise et
en fait et en fait donc il ya ce truc là
et le type dit à la jeune fille dans ce
monde il ya deux choses les ennuis et le
désir le problème c'est que à partir du
moment où tu commences à désirer
quelqu'un sait les ennuis qui commence
voilà donc voilà c'est ce qui arrive à
franck en fait
autant qu'il n'avait pas désiré
quelqu'un et c'est à ce moment là où les
emmerdements commence alors lui il
craque complètement sur elle elle l
aimait les plus jeunes que lui hélas
cette phrase qui correspond à trausse me
il faut avoir un peu confiance ouais
c'est joli c'est elle qui a eu tant de
moins qui lui dit il faut avoir un peu
confiance il ya vincent aussi vincent
pas dont vincent livre ses études à
terre
il redevient sénateurs
mais bien son bouquin j'en suis sûr et
on le dit en rigolant je pense que les
gens sont morts de rire chez eux le
bouquin à preignan il redevient
célibataire mais la vie lui fait
expliquer le choix de sa liberté en fait
ils rentrent ils rencontrent enfin moi
il s'appelait
je me souviens plus du nom de
nancy julien belgy selena n'est pas
bénédicte chez merci ça fait dix ans
qu'on
du team de l'avion tu vois que le père
noël et guy
la saint vincent en fait
durant devient
maçon dumas pas célibataire c'est lequel
devient sénateur alors d'un sens retour
on va l'appeler cécile parce que ses
fils après tout c'est un bon
s'est-il déjà ce n'est pas simple
nicolas s'en retrouve cécile oui voila
sinon la chambre est le colonel moutarde
mais c'est simple pourquoi parce que
vincent retrouve en fait cécile cécile
et son premier amour sont premières
amours en classe de cm1 quand il faisait
du théâtre comme souvent quand on est
enfant on fait du théâtre bien sûr mais
bien sûr voilà
et en fait c'est son premier amour à
jamais disparu donc c'est toute la
thématique de couvrir à 30 ans voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est pourtant ça c'est
à dire que avant on passe son temps à
courir quand on est enfant par exemple
quand quel âge at on enfants je ne sais
pas
trois ans et demi ben voilà à 3h30 il
marche
j'en bouffe et les gens très bien lui il
accepte le mariage avec vous et ce mot
terrible la détestation de l'autre vous
pensez que dans tout couple dans tout
mariage il ya forcément une détestation
de l'autre
parent
j'espère pas de façon comme ça continue
elle met de temps à autre dans un des
grands moments de haine moi étant à eau
dans un lieu tu te couches avec ta femme
tes à quelques millimètres d'elle et
pourtant il ya un océan qui te sépare
d'elle et tu la vois là mais c'est la
règle du jeu il faut l'accepter il faut
accepter de détester l'autre aussi c'est
un bon début c'est comme la dépression
nerveuse il faut accepter d'aller mal
c'est pas une si mauvaise chose il faut
accepter de faire un bide au cinéma
c'est un bon début
bien sûr a dit oui on va pas s'en sortir
mam ne vais pas terrible et des freins
sur la fidélité est une vertu qui
s'exerce par défaut
français dans ta gueule
quel sens dit sa hâte en laisse lui un
peu de temps
dans trois mois on transmet
alors un autre personnage louis qui est
que les baby sitter d'une gamine de 11
ans qui lui saute dessus pour
l'embrasser
en fait c'est l'histoire d'un pédophile
qui ne l'est pas puisque comme j'écris
d'encourir à 30 ans il y à quelques
mètres de la rubrique des faits divers
mais ne m'ont pas dans la chambre de
clara et c'est ce qui m'intéressait
c'est la différence entre les nous est
ce qu'on appelle un meurtrier un
pédophile un monstre qu'est ce qui nous
distingue à un moment donné nous de ces
gens-là qu'on donne en pointe en
peinture en pâture je cherchais le mot
exact oui c'est ça en pâture donc voilà
c'est parfois c'est une feuille de
papier à cigarette donc c'est ça qui
m'intéressait c'était de raconter ça
quoi voilà alors les piles tu je suis là
oui oui j'ai repris je vais te faire la
cité fait guère
voilà un soir à paul et les autres
en épilogue l'auteur à 70 ans il ya
cette phrase terrible écrire est un
métier aussi dégoûtant qu'un autre un
métier où plus personne n'a le choix il
faut aller aux signatures il faut faire
semblant d'écouter les gens qui parlent
de tes livres il faut être capable de
faire commerce de sa vie privée pour dix
mille exemplaires de plus l'époque
modiano est terminée c'est fini écrivait
alors non parce que le fils répond non
c'est toi qui t'es corrompus c'est toi
qui qui qui a choisi mais le père dit
non je n'avais pas le choix à ce moment
là il fallait il fallait faire commerce
de sa vie privée pour vendre dix mille
exemplaires de plus et est en fait le
fisc lui dit on a toujours le choix y
compris de ne pas faire commerce de ce à
quoi voilà donc non je pense que c'est
pas fini loin de là et heureusement
d'ailleurs la preuve le clézio se vend
très bien en ce moment donc non c'est
plutôt une bonne chose mais je jeu en
même temps évidemment
ce dernier chapitre
c'est
c'était une façon à moi de pouvoir
raconter ce que j'avais vécu depuis mes
premiers livres c'est à dire que j'ai
aussi joué sur le fait de faire commerce
un peu de ce que j' étais quoi et de ma
vie privée est souvent à
attaquer ou poser des questions
là-dessus et puis j'avais envie d'en
d'en parler parce que ça fait du bien
d'en parler non mais c'est en fait la
promo c'est un truc marrant là on rigole
et tout mais dans trois mois quand ça
sera fini sa trempe très triste tu te
dis mais jusqu'où je suis allé pour
vendre mon livre est vraiment il fallait
faire ça ou pas ça va voilà ça va plutôt
bien cool on a rigolé non c'était cool
20 mais non mais c'est un vrai truc
tension c'est normalement c'était cacher
que tu vends mon garçon c'est clair mais
normalement un écrivain c'est déjà assez
chiant kaout de faim de passer deux ans
à faire du mieux possible pour faire un
livre et en plus après il faut il faut
vraiment mouillé sa chemise mais ces
voix là
à
30 ans c'est éviter au diable honneur
messieurs et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
mettait un peu de bleu